day five americans trapped behind enemy
lines pretty much well they're being
held at the whim of the taliban yes a
terrorist organization on sunday the
entire country of afghanistan fell to
the taliban
as joe biden gears up for yet another
long weekend in delaware
wow uh only the mohamed karzai
international airport remains under u.s
control at this hour tonight thousands
of americans and thousands of our allies
hopelessly stranded all over the country
as we said behind enemy lines at this
hour the biden administration they still
don't know exactly how many joe's
estimating about fifteen thousand they
don't know where they're located they
can't even tell us
exactly how many have been evacuated and
worst of all they have zero plan to
rescue any americans and according to
the wall street journal this is the
return of america held hostage some 15
000 u.s citizens and residents are
behind taliban lines and there's no easy
way to get them out that's just a fact
they've allowed it to get that bad and
as we speak there are other countries at
least trying and they're extracting
their citizens with their special forces
for example the british are calling it
operation pitting but the united states
as of now has no such program in a press
conference the department of defense
told us that the u.s military is under
orders to protect
the karzai international airport and
that is it according to the state
department in a memo with quote the
united states government cannot ensure
safe passage to the
mohammed karzai international airport
but they're suggesting people might
think about going there but we can't
provide you safe passage there so we're
securing an airport that people will
take great risk to get to
only someone as stupid as joe biden
could come up with a plan like that of
course now he's going on vacation again
according to reports the biden
administration they're looking for what
they call non-military ways to move
americans to the airport past the
taliban
okay i'd like to know what that might be
what are the plans look at your screen
because this is what it looks like
outside of the airport it is chaos it is
carnage taliban fighters viciously
beating whipping stabbing crowds
seemingly doing it at random shots ring
out constantly
men are abducted on the back of pickup
trucks even american journalists have
come under attack take a look
you can see that some of these taliban
fighters they're just
hopped up on adrenaline or i don't know
why
it's a very dicey situation
suddenly two other taliban charge
towards us
you can see their rifle butt raised to
strike producer brent swales
when the fighters are told we have
permission to report they lower their
weapons and letters
god help every american that's there now
as you can see this is now
beyond dangerous anyone making their way
to the airport they are literally
putting their life in the hands of the
same vicious terrorists yep that allowed
the plotting and planning and scheming
of 9 11 2001 but according to joe biden
it's all going according to plan
knock on wood take a look at this
granted it took two days to take control
of the airport we have control of the
airport now still a lot of pandemonium
outside the airport well there is but
look
but no one's being killed right now god
forgive me for if i'm wrong about that
but no one's being killed right now
no one no one's being killed right now
well you're wrong about that people are
being killed and beaten and whipped and
stabbed at checkpoints we have reports
taliban fighters are blocking many from
even getting through and that yet
americans are being told to attempt to
get there but they can't be protected
there's no guarantee of safety now
flights are taking off half empty joe
biden doesn't seem to realize the
magnitude of what is going on and what
led to this mess and how it could have
been prevented take a look what happens
now in afghanistan do you believe the
taliban have changed
no
i think let me put this way
i think they're going through
sort of an existential crisis about do
they want to be recognized by the
international community as being a
legitimate government
i'm not sure they do
but look i i'm not sure i would have
predicted george nor would you or anyone
else that when we decided to leave that
they provide safe passage for americans
to get out
existential crisis safe passage from
terrorists okay when you saw that the
taliban took over 10 percent of the
country 20 percent of the country 30
percent of the country 40 percent of the
country
why was there no urgency then
does this like look safe to you joe
biden as you make your way back to
delaware would you want one of your
loved ones outside of that airport
behind enemy lines getting pistol whip
getting beaten getting shot or just in
fear of all the above look at your
screen these are afghan families
literally passing their babies over a
wall covered with razor wire
begging the british to take their
children because they know that their
children will be murdered by the taliban
if they don't get inside of that airport
think how desperate a mother or father
would have to be to do such a thing
but they do it because that's all they
think they can do to save their kids
because they know how the pa what the
taliban is all about and how they treat
people
now there is no safe passage not for the
afghan people not for americans not for
the allies not for the interpreters that
we promised we'd protect and now we're
witnessing what is one of the biggest
hostage situations in the history of the
us and the biggest military debacle in
the history of the u.s and you have a
president so checked out that he's
spending most of his spare hours on
vacation with no plan except that well
the taliban has said that they're going
to allow safe passage to the airport
when we know that's not happening
considering they have multiple
checkpoints they have surrounded the
entire perimeter of the airport and
nobody is getting through unless they
get
taliban permission and even worse so
many innocent souls are already dead but
according to biden is this is really
much ado about nothing apparently take a
look
we've all seen the pictures we've seen
those hundreds of people packed into a
c-17 we've seen
afghans falling was four days ago five
days ago well you don't think this could
have been handled the sex it could have
been handled
better in any way no mistakes
no i i don't think it could have been
handled in a way that they're
we're going to go back in hindsight and
look but the idea that somehow
there's a way to have gotten out without
chaos ensuing i don't know how that
happens
well you could have done it before they
made their march to kabul you didn't
have to give them
air force base either you could have
acted earlier it didn't have to go
chaotically it could have gone very
smoothly logistics could have been
employed we could have had a plan to
extract identify every american and get
them out weeks before but biden said
that a taliban takeover well it was not
inevitable joe was just telling us that
a couple of weeks ago he was reassuring
the american people that the afghan army
one of the most capable well-trained
armies in in the world and that they
even had an air force and that only 75
000 taliban and then the taliban makes
their march in every step of the way joe
apparently didn't notice he said there'd
be no chaotic scenes at the u.s embassy
in kabul with helicopters scenes similar
to the fall of saigon in 75. yeah we
have those scenes and then he pulled
american soldiers out in the middle of
the night he abandoned bagram air base
he dismantled trump's contingency in
crisis response bureau that was back in
june he dismantled that that was set up
by president trump and secretary of
state pompeo to provide aviation
logistics medical support to americans
if they get trapped abroad why would you
have gotten rid of that program
and joe stood by and did nothing as the
taliban made all of these rapid advances
all over the country in the past two
months they acted like it wasn't
happening in fact an internal state
department cable in july actually warned
of kabul's imminent collapse
joe did nothing and now we're
experiencing what is the single worst
foreign policy crisis and debacle ever
the lives of thousands of americans are
literally in the hands of evil
terrorists our afghan partners they have
been abandoned and left for dead and i
can promise you those left behind will
die gruesome deaths our allies rightly
no longer trust us our enemies are only
emboldened billions of dollars in u.s
weapons they didn't have a plan to
remove them or at least destroy them you
know night vision goggles planes
helicopters up armored vehicles yeah
that you paid for they're now in the
hands of the taliban that makes them
even stronger and today joe biden had no
public events again called the lid i'm
done at 3 30 in the afternoon no press
briefing i guess jen saki's back on
vacation because we didn't hear from her
we haven't heard a word from kamala
harris in more than a week and thousands
of american lives are at risk at this
hour the bight administration is
completely totally detached and out to
lunch this is by every definition of
dereliction of duty if joe biden is not
up for this job now we've joked about it
we've kidded about it we've shown you
the video
and then we stop laughing about it
because it's not funny because seeing a
joe biden weak and frail and a cognitive
mess
um is not good for the united states
it's not good for our fellow citizens
those trapped behind enemy lines tonight
and it's not good for the world either
if he doesn't care
about the lives of americans abroad if
he's not up to this job he needs to
either step down or be removed if he
just wants to live out his remaining
days on a beach in delaware i'm fine
with that step down let someone more
capable take over someone that may have
a sense of urgency about how dire this
situation is and the amount of potential
power and leverage that he has now
single-handedly given a terrorist
organization and god forbid what i can
think of in my mind which i will not
express they could do to the americans
held behind enemy lines we pray for
those americans every one of them we
want them home safely they're trapped in
afghanistan we pray for our friends we
pray for our allies who have been
abandoned and pray also that as many
lives as possible hopefully
prayerfully every life will be saved
before it's too late
if it does work out that way
it will be a miracle a modern day
miracle but it won't be because of
anything joe biden did hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else